うさ耳目社長種
まず
言いたいことは一つです
前田した不利だポットの動画う
と色々終わってやってさせていただきました
まあ皆さんお気づきの通りしちゃう
ちょっと下ネタ打ち込み過ぎて
ちょっとやらかしちゃった感じですねああ
ボクは嫌いですしっかり編集して
みんなに受け入れられる動画に
して
リメイクしました
おらでも諦めないからどんなことがあっても
だけで再 up スターでどうぞ
ゴリラポッドって知ってますか
これでこういう年
なんか
見たいんですけど言っちゃあがここにカメラを置いて
こうなんか
なんだ
みたいな
ちょっと重めの
あったらこうなんかね分かるでしょやっぱりあれですよ
んですよこうなっちゃうんですよそんな積んでも僕はこれを
なんかこれどんぐらいか7000円からちょっと高くて
だったんですけど
最近見たらまああてて買いました
ここです柱けどこんなに大きさが違います
えっ
うん
すげー
tan
大
恋
なぜそうでたらダメですこれ本当にパッド winter すっごいてっぷ子ですよね
うん
白井タウンんですよこれならきっとこれもあれ
あの大木さんはあの大きさ壁掛けねこれ減らないよじゃ寝入らないか言わない入らない
はっユニバーサルだけど全然宇宙ここが入れる
ぱなんですけど入らないんですよこれじゃただの
tee